One of assessing how emotionally damaged we might be is to identify
a range of markers of emotional health and
imagine how we fare in relation to them. At
least four central themes suggest themselves.
Firstly Self-Love. Self-love is the quality that determines
how much we can be friends with ourselves
and, day to day, remain on our own side. When
we meet a stranger who has things we don’t,
how quickly do we feel ourselves pitiful – and
how long can we remain assured by the decency
of what we have and are? When another person
frustrates or humiliates us, can we let the
insult go, able to perceive the senseless
malice beneath the attack – or are we left
brooding and devastated, implicitly identifying
with the verdict of our enemies? How much
can the disapproval or neglect of public opinion
be offset by the memory of the steady attention
of few significant people in the past? In
relationships, do we have enough self-love
to leave an abusive union? Or are we so down
on ourselves that we carry an implicit belief
that harm is all we deserve? In a different
vein, how good are we at apologising to a
lover for things that may be our fault? How
rigidly self-righteous do we need to be? Can
we dare to admit mistakes or does an admission
of guilt or error bring us too close to our
background sense of nullity? In the bedroom,
how clean and natural or alternatively disgusting
and sinful do our desires feel? Might they
be a little odd, but not for that matter bad
or dark, since they emanate from within us
and we are not wretches? At work, do we have
a reasonable, well-grounded sense of our worth
– and so feel able to ask for (and properly
expect to get) the rewards we are due? Can
we resist the need to please others indiscriminately?
Are we sufficiently aware of our genuine contribution
to say no? Candour Candour determines the
extent to which difficult ideas and troubling
facts can be consciously admitted into the
mind, soberly explored and accepted without
denial. How much can we admit to ourselves
about who we are – even if, or especially
when, the matter is not especially pleasant?
How much do we need to insist on our own normality
and wholehearted sanity? Can we explore our
own minds – and look into their darker and
more troubled corners without flinching overly?
Can we admit to folly, envy, sadness and confusion?
Around others, how ready are we to learn?
Do we need always take a criticism of one
part of us as an attack on everything about
us? How ready are we to listen when valuable
lessons come in painful guises? Communication
Can we patiently and reasonably put our disappointments
into words that, more or less, enable others
to see our point? Or do we internalise pain,
act it out symbolically or discharge it with
counterproductive rage? When other people
upset us, do we feel we have the right to
communicate or must we slam doors and retreat
into sulks? When the desired response isn’t
forthcoming, do we ask others to guess what
we have been too angrily panicked to spell
out? Or can we have a plausible second go
and take seriously the thought that others
are not merely being nasty in misunderstanding
us? Do we have the inner resources to teach
rather than insist? Trust How risky is the
world? How readily might we survive a challenge
in the form of a speech, a romantic rejection,
a bout of financial trouble, a journey to
another country or a common cold? How close
are we, at any time, to catastrophe? What
material are we made of? Will new acquaintances
like or wound us? If we are a touch assertive,
will they take it or collapse? Will unfamiliar
situations end in a debacle? Around love,
how tightly do we need to cling? If they are
distant for a while, will they return? How
controlling do we need to be? Can we approach
an interesting-looking stranger? Or move on
from an unsatisfying one? Do we, overall,
feel the world to be wide, safe, and reasonable
enough for us to have a legitimate shot at
a measure of contentment – or must we settle,
resentfully, for inauthenticity and misunderstanding?
It isn’t our fault or, in a sense, anyone
else’s that many of these questions are
so hard to answer in the affirmative. But,
by entertaining them, we are at least starting
to know what kind of shape our psycological wounds have and so what kind of bandages might be most necessary.
If you liked this film, please subscribe to our channel and click the bell icon to turn on notifications.
If you want to learn more about Self-Knowledge follow the link on your screen now to see our range of books, games and gifts all about Self-Knowledge.